I got lucky I feel like the longer I've
been playing the game the more I do
believe that luck is a massive
contributor to success I was born in
America to a family of people that
didn't struggle to feed me or give me
education I was born bilingual so
language and communication came easier
to me to know a friend of my own I had
two parents who spoke different
languages so I think a lot of people
discount and they love to be like all
right I'm here because I'm so hard ass
it's like yeah but if you were born in
like Bangladesh as a woman you probably
wouldn't be that successful just real it
takes a big stretch of positive like
yeah we lucked out and if you can watch
this from your iPhone you're probably
lucky too